Mister Beast l'a fait 1000 personnes qui
retrouvent la vue juste avec une
opération de 10 minutes ça paraît dingue
mais alors on pourrait tout le monde
c'est juste une question d'argent pas
tout à fait on va cesser le M tout de
suite être aveugle ce n'est pas voir
tout noir la plupart des personnes
atteintes de ces cités conservent une
partie de leur vision c'est le cas pour
les patients dans la vidéo tous atteints
de cataracte derrière votre pupille se
trouve une petite lentille qu'on appelle
le cristalin son rôle est de recevoir la
lumière pour la faire parvenir à votre
rétine il est composé à 90 % d'une
protéin assurant la transparence mais
lorsqu'elle se dégrade la lumière passe
moins bien et l'image devient floue
c'est la principale raison de céciter
dans le monde normal ça peut se
déclencher de plein de façons
différentes vs mode de vie diabète ou
même hérédité comment on soigne ça alors
faites votre choix le scapel ou le laser
la seule différence c'est la taille de
l'incision le chirurgien ouvre
légèrement l'extérieur de l'œil ça va
permettre d'injecter un gel de
protection et passer à travers l'iris
pour ouvrir le cristallin on insère
ensuite une sonde qui va émettre des
ultrasons ça va briser les blocs de
protéines et il y a plus qu'à tout
aspirer une fois vide on retire la poche
la remplaçant par une lentille
artificielle elle est faite en matériaux
transparent totalement inerte pas de
rejet possible il en existe plein de
types différents car elle corrig aussi
la vue des lunettes intégrées
directement dans l'œil pourtant même si
c'est si simple seulement 17 % des
malades ont recours le plus souvent pour
des raisons d'argent ou d'accès au soins
ce n'est pas la seule maladie pouvant
créer des problèmes oculaires à chaque
fois c'est pour des raisons différentes
alors peut-on recréer un œil abîmé
est-ce que la chirurgie laser peut vous
rendre aveugle la science peut répondre
à tout ça peut-on avoir un œil bionique
ça c'est le futur pouvoir créer des
globes oculair interchangeable comme
dans cyberpunk pourra ressentir une
légère gêne au début un petit problème
de vue et hop je mets à jour le système
pour régler ça un œil qui fonctionne pas
pas de souci je vais vous le changer
vous préférez rouge ou bleu on a encore
du chemin mais les scientifiques ont
déjà commencé le travail en 2020
l'Université de Hong Kong présente ça
c'est en regardant des films de
science-fiction que le chercheur a voulu
créer un super œil humain et ça ça
fonctionne l'image passe à travers une
lentille pour être projetée sur la
rétine chez nous elle est constituée de
photorécepteur le bâtonnet forme toute
la périphérie et capte les faibles
lumières permettant de voir la nuit la
partie centrale est constituée de petits
cônes indispensable à la vision le jour
mais surtout à percevoir les couleurs et
la netté de notre environnement quand
une lumière est captée il transmettent
l'information au air optique sous forme
d'impulsion électrique c'est le cerveau
qui traduira ça en image dans leur
protèes ils ont utilisé des nanotubes en
pirov kit à la place un métal sensible à
la lumière qu'on retrouve dans des
panneaux ils sont si petits que leur
prototype contient 30 fois plus de
récepteurs que l'œil humain avec autant
de résolution même la 4K paraît flou en
plus la forme de l'implant permet de
créer une vision périphérique similaire
à la nôtre je vous vois venir il y a les
caméras fâchales qui permettaient de
voir à grand angle oui mais la vue est
déformée les lignes se courbent et tout
ce qui est proche de l'appareil grossit
si on voyait comme ça on tituberait à
chaque pas il y a juste un tout petit
problème les matériaux utilisés ne sont
pas biocompatibles si on le graisse sur
quelqu'un il y aura un rejet le corps ne
le ne reconnaît pas comme faisant partie
de l'organisme et déclenche le système
immunitaire pour éradiquer la menace les
méthau utilisés peuvent aussi entraîner
un empoisonnement retrouver la vue au
péril de sa vie est un Paris risqué en
attendant qu'il trouve la solution une
technologie existe déjà depuis 2011 elle
est commercialisé en Europe donc vous
l'avez peut-être déjà vu une paire de
lunettes sur lesquelles sont installées
des caméras elles vont détecter les
variations de lumière et les
retransmettre directement à un implant
placé sous la rétine on le pose après
une opération de plusieurs heures sous
les parties ou les photos récepteur ne
fonctionne plus il est composé de 60
électrodes qui vont émettre des
impulsions électriques lorsqu'elles
reçoivent un signal ça va stimuler le
nerf optique et créer une image dans le
cerveau c'est loin d'être un retour à
une vue normale d'après les patients ça
ressemble plus à des zones lumineuses
permettant de voir les contrastes ça
permet à des personnes comme ces
strasbourgeoisees de pouvoir retrouver
une partie de leur autonomie c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très de très
merveilleux pour moi et s'il fallait
recommencer j'y retournerai tout de
suite une équipe de l'université de
Stanford a même présenté sa version plus
évoluée la caméra montée filme
l'environnement et un ordinateur de
poche convertit l'image en rayon
infrarouge les ondes vont être projetées
sur un écran réfléchissant fixé sur le
vert des lunettes comme ça elles
reviennent dans l'œil et peuvent être
détectés par l'implant c'est du top
qualité des mini cellules
photovoltaïques un seul appareil de
quelques millimètres peut en contenir
des centaines ça permet aux patients de
détecter beaucoup plus de détails en
plus elle fonctionne comme des panneaux
solaires en s'alimentant elle-même avec
la lumière qu'ell reçoivent pas besoin
de retourner se faire charcuter pour
changer la batterie leur technologie a
vu le jour en 2012 et des essais
cliniques sont en cours ces appareils
sont utilisés quand la maoua et les
cônes sont trop abîmés pour fonctionner
souvent à cause de l'âge tout le centre
de la vue devient flou lorsque vous
parlez à quelqu'un vous ne voyez plus
son visage la rétine est très fragile et
d'autres problèmes peuvent nécessiter
l'installation d'un implant les
vaisseaux situés dans le globe oculaire
peuvent éclater à cause de maladie ils
vont alors déverser des liquides
derrière la membrane ça forme des poches
qui en gonflant coupent complètement la
connexion entre les cellules et le nerf
optique les victimes voir apparaître de
grosses taches noires dans le champ de
vision on appelle ça une rétinite même
les nouvenés peuvent être atteints après
la couche ement les vaisseaux de l'œil
continuent de grandir et de se former
une naissance prématurée perturbe tout
ça et il pousse en trop grand nombre
dans 90 % des cas il finissent par se
rétracter et tout rentre dans l'ordre
mais parfois il se raccroche il faut
alors intervenir pour éviter qu'il
n'arrache la rétine une maladie
héréditaire peut aussi abîmer cette zone
elle est du à une mutation sur les gènes
qui régulle les photorécepteurs il se
dégrade bien trop vite les premiers
symptômes se déclenchent chez les jeunes
de 10 à 30 ans au début c'est rien du
tout on voit moins bien le soir on met
plus de temps à s'adapter dans une pièce
sombre mais bon c'est sûrement la
fatigue rien de bien de grave en fait
c'est parce que les bâtonnets ont
commencé à se détruire et ne se
renouvellent pas comme il constitu
l'extérieur de la rétine le champ de
vision se réduit c'est comme si vous
regardiez à travers un tube on devient
plus maladroit on se cogne dans des
objets qu'on avait pas vu on finit même
par trébucher car on ne voit plus les
objets à ses pieds avec le temps les
cônes vont aussi être touchées on
commence à moins bien percevoir
certaines couleurs ça va jusqu'à
craindre la lumière du jour car elle est
trop violente au bout de quelques années
ça peut être la cécité totale la
destruction se voit depuis l'extérieur
ça va créer de petites tâes de pigment
dans l'œil d'où son nom dans ce cas
l'implant peut permettre de récupérer un
peu de vision et d'autonomie mais l'œil
reste abîmé d'autres recherches essaient
de trouver une solution permettant de
réparer les dégâts greffer de nouvelles
cellules pour relier l'information notre
corps se sert de l'électricité elle
passe d'un neurone à l'autre pour faire
bouger un muscle envoyer des images au
cerveau ou résoudre un bon problème de
mathématique mais on va pas se mentir
c'est le bordel il y a des fils dans
tous les sens et dans le cerveau c'est
pire impossible de savoir qui s'occupe
de quoi alors pour comprendre les
scientifiques ont eu une idée
implémenter des molécules réagissant à
la lumière dans des neuros à chaque fois
qu'on les éclaire elle génère du courant
qui force l'activation des cellules
c'est comme un interrupteur on off on
peut donc voir l'activité qu'une zone du
cerveau régule dans le corps ça
s'appelle l'optogénétique une équipe de
chercheurs franco-suisse a mise en place
ce système sur des cellules du nerf
optique celle situé juste derrière la
rétine en temps normal elles reçoivent
les informations des cônes et des
bâtonnets pour les envoyer au cerveau
mais lorsqu'ils sont défectueux bah
elles reçoivent plus rien plus de
courant plus d'image alors griffant la
protéine photosensible elles vont
elles-mêm créer du courant lorsqu'elles
reçoivent la lumière qui a atteint nos
yeux elles deviennent donc donc des
photorécepteurs après des essais en
laboratoire un patient a pu participer à
l'étude après 5 mois pour s'assurer que
les cellules ganglionires soient stables
et cette mois de réudication le résultat
tombe ça marche il arrive à repérer et
toucher un cahier placé dans une pièce
dans 92 % de ses tentatives il en était
incapable avant bon par contre lui aussi
a besoin de lunettes spécial parce que
la molécule ne réagit pas à tous les
types d'éclairage en temps normal il se
sert de la lumière bleu car c'est la
plus présente et la plus puissante sauf
qu'elle est dangereuse pour notre rétine
une trop longue exposition l'abîme et
accélère l'apparition de maladie c'est
pour ça qu'on vous conseille avec
l'équipe de réduire le temps que vous
passez devant les écrans ils en ont donc
choisi une sensible à une lumière plus
douce et totalement inoffensive bon par
contre il y en a pas beaucoup dans notre
environnement donc il faut encore une
caméra qui convertit l'image et la
projette vers l'œil pour que la molécule
la repère si on veut une solution qui se
passe d'accessoire il faut se tourner
vers les cellules souches vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler dans un épisode
de South Park c'est celle qu'on retrouve
chez les fetus elles sont immatures et
n'ont pas encore de rôle elles peuvent
donc changer pour devenir n'importe quoi
chez l'adulte aussi il y en a mais elles
peuvent seulement évoluer dans leur
organe d'origine une cellule de
l'estomac ne pourra pas servir à réparer
le cœur dans une étude on a injecté
celle d'un humain sur la rétine abîmée
d'un chien résultat elles sont allées
jusqu'au parties abîmées pour créer des
liaisons et réparer les trous c'est que
le début mais c'est déjà prometteur ça
pourrait rendre la vue à des personnes
quel que soit leur maladie je vois venir
pourquoi se prendre la tête à recréer
des cellules d'un œil alors qu'on
pourrait juste greffer un nouveau ça
paraît quand même bien plus simple on le
fait déjà pour des poumons ou le cœur
c'est des organes vitaux donc un œil à
côté c'estasy et bien non c'est beaucoup
plus dur le challenge c'est de le
rattacher au nerf optique c'est pas
juste brancher une prise et regarder si
ça marche il est relié à chaque
photorécepteur par le prolongement d'un
neurone pour chaque œil ça représente
entre 770000 et 1,7 million de
connexions faudrait attacher chaque
cellule une par une pour que ça
fonctionne impossible de le faire à la
main et la technologie est pas assez
avancée pour nous y aider c'est pour ça
que la maladie qui touche cette zone
doivent être traité le plus rapidement
possible les dégâts sont irréversibles
c'est ce qui arrive aux personnes
atteintes de glocome quand tout va bien
notre œil sécrète un liquide qui
contient des nutriments il passe au
travers du cristallin pour nourrir les
cellules et continue son chemin à
travers la pupille avant d'arriver à
l'œil où il sera évacué à travers un
filtre mais avec l'âge ù si l'iris
bloque le passage bah le filtre peut se
boucher et là faut agir très vite parce
que le liquide va s'accumuler prendre de
plus en plus de place et pousser sur le
cristallin votre œil se fait écraser par
sa bouche plus il pousse plus la rétine
comprime le nerf optique jusqu'à
détruire ses cellules c'est celle le
plus à l'extérieur qui sont touchés en
premier créant une vision en tunnel le
même résultat peut arriver si le nerf
est comprimé par une tum ou s'il
viissent trop vite en France 800000
personnes sont traitées mais on estime
que plus de 400000 sont atteintes sans
le savoir vous croisez tous les jours
des gens qui sont aveugles sans vous en
rendre compte pour certains d'entre eux
il existe quand même des solutions la
chirurgie laser et la thérapie pas
besoin de lunettes de soleil et de canes
pour être malvoyant certains voient même
mieux que vous mais leur angle de vision
est tellement réduit que c'est comme
marcher dans la rue en regardant dans
des tubes en carton faites l'essai ça
devient très dur de ne pas percuter
quelque chose ou de voir une voiture
quand on veut traverser la route les
troubles classiques de vue peuvent
également mener à la cécité la loi
française reconnaît qu'on est aveugle si
notre vue est inférieure à 1/ 20 pour le
meilleur œil avec port de lunett comme
pour les cas moins graves la chirurgie
peut t'aider à réduire les troubles sans
pour autant rendre une vue complète pour
ça il ne va pas nous falloir un laser
mais deux le premier est capable de
tirer un rayon durant quelques fêes aux
secondes pourquoi aussi court car plus
le temps est long plus la puissance est
diluée ils sont utilisés dans tous les
domaines scientifiques ces brefs pics de
puissance permettent de réaliser des
fusions nucléaires ou même de générer
des particules élémentaires les plus
grosses au monde fonctionnent sur cette
technologie un seul tir peut dégager 20
fois plus d'énergie que DF en produit
sur une année pour votre opération le
principe est le même mais pas la
puissance il est 1000 fois moins fort
que ceux qu'on utilise pour faire des
présentations c'est comme même suffisant
pour découper une petite ouverture à la
surface de votre corné si l'ouverture
est très petite on appelle ça la
technique smile pas celle de One Piece
pas d'inquiétude la couche se renouvelle
en permanence tous les ans la surface de
votre œil est entièrement neuve le
deuxième laser peut alors prendre la
relève il contient un gaz rare ainsi
qu'un halogène lorsque le mélange subit
une décharge électrique les atomes vont
s'exciter pour devenir plus stable ils
vont s'associer pour créer des molécules
et existant seulement dans cet état
lorsqu'on stoppe l'alimentation en
électricité ils reprennent leur forme
normale en libérant des photons ils sont
tous dirigés vers le même point grâce à
des miroirs pour obtenir un laser
ultraviolet pourquoi des ultraviolets
car ils sont bien absorbés par les
composés organiques qui constituent
notre corps ça va créer des ruptures
dans les couches moléculaires sur
lesquelles le rayon vient taper pour
faire simple ça va permettre à des
petits morceaux de la rétine de se
détacher sans générer de brûlure ou de
coupure en quelques secondes le laser va
tirer plusieurs centaines de fois à des
endroits très précis à l'œil nu
impossible de voir la différence mais
c'est suffisant pour corriger le passage
de la lumière et résoudre votre problème
de lunett à jamais niveau convalescence
vous êtes tranquille aussi de quelques
heures à 48h de petitte gène avant de
profiter pleinement de votre nouvelle
vue les avis sont unanimes personne ne
regrette son opération il existe aussi
la méthode PKR où la première incision
est faite manuellement par le chirurgien
la convalescence est plus douloureuse et
dure plusieurs jours mais le
fonctionnement est le même mais
l'opération a l'avantage de coûter moins
cher d'autres problèmes de vu peuvent
être résolu grâce à de leur réudication
ou des opérations chirurgicales c'est le
cas des strabismes légers le musc qui
contrôle l'œil fonctionne mal ce qui le
rend difficile à diriger pour éviter ça
on camoufleil sain pour forcer le
cerveau à faire travailler l'autre comme
un bon entraînement à la salle allez on
fait travailler ces petits muscles no
pain no gain si c'est pas suffisant
l'opération peut devenir obligatoire on
va chercher à raccourcir ou allonger les
muscles situés sur le côté de l'œil tout
dépend du type de strabisme que vous
avez raccourcir un muscle je veux bien
il suffit de couper mais comment peut-on
le rallonger on peut pas vraiment par
contre on peut le détacher du globe
oculaire pour le repositionner à un
autre endroit en ajustant les deux côtés
on peut ramener une vue normale à une
personne atteinte mais ça demande
ensuite beaucoup de rééducation ces
opérations peuvent se révéler
nécessaires car avec le temps le cerveau
peut bloquer toutes les informations qui
arrivent de l'œil strabique il arrive
même qu'à la naissance les yeux
fonctionnent parfaitement mais le
cerveau n'arrive pas à traiter
l'information l'image peut être floue en
tunnel coupé à moitié impossible de
prédire la seule solution est la
neuroplasticité non on ne met pas de
neurones en plastique dans la tête des
enfants c'est la capacité qu'à votre
cerveau à créer de nouvelles connexions
lorsque vous vous développez comme quand
vous jouez à des jeux de mémoire ici
c'est pareil grâce à des ex exercice
spécifique ça va renforcer la zone qui
traduit les images la vue de la plupart
des enfants s'améliore après quelques
années car le cerveau a été reprogrammé
mais chacun est différent et les
résultats ne sont pas assurés il reste
encore beaucoup de chemins pour guérir
complètement la ccité c'est pour ça que
de nombreuses associations milit pour
sensibiliser et faire connaître le
combat que vivent les malvoyants au
quotidien depuis le début du siècle
beaucoup d'études ont vu le jour
apportant des solutions qui n'étaient
pas réalisable jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
génétique nous permettra peut-être
bientôt de détecter une personne aveugle
avant même sa naissance permettant ainsi
de cultiver ses propres cellules souches
pour le guérir ou bien peut-être que la
réalité augmentée pourra permettre de
stimuler directement le
cerveau